the gyro can experience you've um you've
kicked the green [ __ ] yes yes
after a 24-year intense relationship
with the Green Goddess or the green
[ __ ] depending on what mood she's in
I had to stop and I've come in for some
I've come in for some some criticism for
this and and I feel it's important to
say that I hugely value and love
cannabis I think it's a wonderful herbal
ally and I think that I don't think that
I would ever have written my books of
historical mystery if I had not
encountered cannabis rather late in life
I did not smoke any dope until I was 37
years old and I'm now 62 Wow and roughly
rad about the age of 38 that's when I
started getting into historical
mysteries course it's total stoner stuff
before that it was all curved affairs
you know right so but suddenly something
opened up for me and I'm very and I'm
very grateful to the herb for that and
initially my real again I need to
emphasize this I think the problem I
eventually ended up having with cannabis
it's not the fault of cannabis it's the
fault of Graham Hancock I think my
relationship became abusive with the
herb it was not initially initially it
was something I would do evenings and
weekends I would not try to write while
I was actually stoned I would do my
day's work and then chill out in the
evening with a pipe or a joint that was
that was high was for me for quite a
while and I went through my first big
historical mystery book the sign and the
seal which was published in 1992 with
that pattern in other words that I would
be I would be smoking only after I
downed tools at the end of the evening
and I was ready to chill hmm
and that worked fine but then when I
started when I started writing
fingerprints of the Gods which was the
biggest book I've ever done a five
million copy bestseller all around the
world when I started writing that I
thought I'll experiment let's see if I
can be stoned and write
and I discovered that I could I could
bestow that right and I like being stuff
so much that in a way it urged me to
just write all the time you know because
then I had this I had this incredibly
good reason to be stoned all the time
and took away all the physical boredom
of sitting there in my chair in front of
my computer screen just everything went
away and I went and drifted into this
space where I could explore ideas and
manifest those ideas down down on the
page and I literally that's when I began
what was to become ultimately an abusive
relationship with cannabis was that I
would fire up in those days my joint or
my pipe at 9:00 or 10:00 in the morning
and I would I'm a hard worker
I work 16 hours a day very often when
I'm writing so come two o'clock the next
morning I'd still be there smoking away
and as the years went by this became a
permanent daily pattern for me whether I
was writing or not I would be stoned
from the moment I got up until the
moment I went to bed and most people who
came by my house or talked to me on the
phone they would have had absolutely no
idea because I was I was completely in
control I didn't seem high I could hold
a rational conversation I was I was just
fine
and I just felt I just felt really good
and this is how it went on for many
years and later on about in the early to
that round about 2005 actually I think
perhaps a little earlier one of my kids
told me that you know this stuff the
smoke is you don't need to have
combustion products why don't you use a
vaporizer so I bought myself a volcano
on the internet and and and then I heard
that the British government was going to
ban the use of ban old peripherals so I
bought myself two more volcanoes
volcanoes are quite expensive but that
shows how dedicated I was make sure you
cover your bases I had to make sure that
I covered my bases and then I would be
vaporizing from 9:00 in the morning
until 2:00 o'clock the next morning
seven days a weekend and increasingly
strong strains and this is one thing
that I would say if we lived in a regime
an irrational regime where there was no
attempt by the government to police our
states of consciousness
we could have much more choice in the
kind of cannabis we get hold of for
example I would have liked to have
canvas with much more CBD and maybe less
th see when the varieties I was smoking
were very very th THC loaded that's the
difference in effect well okay I mean
there depends how much you buy into the
research on this but but the a lot of
good science has been done and the
suggestion is that THC can promote or
reveal I don't want to I don't want to
blame the herb for anything I it can
reveal certain psychotic tendencies in
oneself hmm and this is the well-known
paranoia which which many people
associate with with smoking cannabis the
CBD is an anti-psychotic agent so the
natural herb is balanced with CBD and
THC and and it looks after you very well
but where we go into intensive reading
of the herb focusing on the element that
makes you really high which is the THC
then we get get a herb that is somewhat
unbalanced as a result of the
interference of humanity and and and but
you get more bang for your buck you know
that's a very that's a very strong herb
and and I began to like a particular
variety called cheese I think it's
called cheese because it smells like you
know old socks or Stilton you know like
a blue cheese mhm and I found a grower
who lived local to me who was just
having amazing green fingers and and I
would I would buy from him and and I
would sometimes have you know five or
six ounces of the herb in my house
because I was blazing through this stuff
at a tremendous at a tremendous rate
that's enough to you you could get in
trouble well that's it so that so that's
where the paranoia starts to become
legitimate you know because actually
they can no they can't break down your
door and they can confiscate your home
and take away your liberty and [ __ ] you
up forever you know they can do that and
and so every time I heard a ring at the
door or you know a Carl came up the
street I would I would you know get
paranoid get paranoid and you were high
so that was high
did you get paranoid when you were high
well this is one of the reasons why look
what happened to me was that run about
2003 I started for reasons of research
initially working with ayahuasca the the
vine of souls this is the the powerful
psychedelic brew which has been consumed
by shamanistic cultures in the Amazon
for thousands and thousands of years and
it's not called the vine of souls for
nothing it's a it's it's an
extraordinary portal into other realms
and and in some ways those realms are
associated with death and perhaps what
waits for us after death nobody knows
the answer to that but in ayahuasca you
have certain experiences relating to
that and right from the beginning when I
started to drink ayahuasca I mean this
sounds nuts to anybody who hasn't done
DMT or who hasn't drunk ayahuasca but
you do meet intelligent entities and
more and more around the world people
drinking ayahuasca are meeting this
goddess figure she might appear as a
serpent she might appear as a woman she
might appear as some kind of panther or
Jaguar very powerful tough love kind of
lady who reveals to you the truth about
yourself and just says you know you
[ __ ] deal with it because that's how
you are and and what the truth that was
revealed to me from quite early on was
my relationship with cannabis had got
out of balance and I needed to get it
back into balance and of course I
ignored those messages completely
because I was so I was so much in love
with my cannabis relationship my wife
said that really it was like a head of
mistress you know who I spend all my
time with was the cat was the cannabis
rather than rather than her and this
went on for many many years now the
paranoia aspect okay I'm going to bare
my heart here and you know I believe in
being honest
the paranoia aspect began to affect my
relationship with my beloved partner
Santha who I just loved from the bottom
of my heart and she is that the best the
most the most pure hearted generous
spirited loving lady it's possible to
possible to imagine but I started to
develop all kinds of suspicions about
her which were completely groundless
I started to imagine all sorts of stuff
going on and then I started to act up
act towards her as though those
suspicions were real and all of this was
also related to my consumption of
cannabis it was not caused by my
consumption of cannabis I think this is
a latent aspect of my own personality it
was being revealed by this over abuse of
of the of the cannabis herb and and
therefore I was making my beautiful
partner's life a misery sometimes not
everyday but sometimes and she was
patiently putting up with this but she
was suffering and we went down to Brazil
in October 2011 and if I had been told
when we got on that plane and went down
to Brazil that when I came back two
weeks later I would probably never smoke
cannabis again I would have laughed in
the face of the person who told me that
but the encounters that I had with the
spirit of ayahuasca whatever that is I'm
willing to accept that there is no
spirit of ayahuasca that it's all
something we generate out of our brains
but for me she manifests as a real like
a goddess and the encounters I had with
that and I do think she's real that's
just my personal belief system right and
those encounters that I had were
incredibly powerful and she took me to a
place that was something like hell and
she took me to a place that was
something like the judgment scene in the
ancient Egyptian religion now the
judgment scene is a place where your
heart is weighed in the scales against
the feather of truth and harmony and
cosmic justice and you do not want your
heart to be heavy in those scales you
want to be able to look back on your
life and say I did good I did not add to
the misery in the world I did something
worthwhile with this incredible gift of
life that the universe gave me and and
everything you've done every second
every minute of your life is completely
transparent every thought every action
everything you did from the moment you
became conscious until the moment of
your death is laid out before you and
there's no hiding from it like we great
at creating illusions about our own
behavior and persuading ourselves that
we're behaving just fine in the
judgement Hall of Osiris which is also
called the Hall of Mart where the scene
takes place all of that stripped away
and you confront the truth and I was put
there and I confronted the truth about
myself and I saw the way
that I was behaving towards my partner
and and and I was shown that that this
had to stop otherwise otherwise I was
going to pay a huge price for it and it
I had a series of terrifying terrifying
experiences which my partner santa-santa
the shared with me because we were
drinking ayahuasca together and at a
certain point entities came to her and
and she had the experience of her heart
being pulled out of her chest and the
entity said to her and she thought she
was going to die and the entity said to
her we're gonna do this to you to teach
grammar lesson and Santa communicated
that to me and I would rank that as
probably the single most terrifying
night of my entire life and I've had
some terrifying nights that was just
absolutely scared rigid and I and I came
out of that with a feeling a very clear
feeling inner in ayahuasca we have
sharings the next day after you've drunk
the brew you share with the rest of the
group who you've drunk with the
experiences you had the night before as
much as you want to share and what I
shared because I still didn't believe
that I could stop smoking cannabis what
I shared was that I was going to change
my relationship with cannabis and and to
get to a place where cannabis was
serving me again rather than me serving
her and and that's what I believed but
when I got back to England long flight
what's the first thing I do I get out my
vaporizer get out my stash fire up the
vaporizer and feel a nice bag of of
vapor you said it's sort of surgical
well I miss it I miss it you know this
was a cannabis is such a beautiful
sensual Ally if she's used right do you
think it's just an imbalance issue with
the CBD THC ratio let me let me just let
me just finish with water with what
happened to me so I fill up the bag and
I'm down there in my basement and I take
the first and I take the first draw and
I'm suddenly filled with the most
intense feelings of horror and loathing
and it is exactly like I'm back in that
space that ayahuasca took me to and I
try a second puff and I can't do it I
physically could not continue I I knew
that I just I just could not continue I
expressed the vapor out of the
i crumpled up the bag i put it away and
the next day i got rid of several ounces
of cannabis yeah I know I know it's
terrible it's a terrible thing to do but
but but for me it was the right thing to
do
24 years non-stop relationship with
cannabis definitely abusing the herb I
had got to the point where the only
rational course of action was what I was
shown in ayahuasca which was to stop and
I don't know whether it was because
there was way too much THC and not
enough CBD or whether it was just me not
being responsible for my own behavior I
go I go around you know saying that I
believe in adult responsibility and I do
but I don't think I was being
responsible I don't think I was using
the herb in a responsible way I don't
think I was using it in a respectful way
and I paid a price for that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Freaks and Geeks